hello good afternoon Ukraine says
Russian missile strikes across the
country have caused deaths and resulted
in huge damage to critical
infrastructure Authority has reported
explosions in a capital cave as well as
the southern city of Kiri Ria and khakif
in the Northeast well I'm now joined by
the former senior British intelligence
and security officer Philip Ingram who's
here with me now and so Philip what's
the latest then that we're getting on
the Russian attacks in Ukraine well day
296 of Putin's 10-day special military
operation and as you said there have
been overnight missile attacks on cave
on criviria on hakive and on Odessa down
in the South and they're attacking the
critical National infrastructure they're
trying to break the will of the people
and they've been missile attacks over
the last few nights using cruise
missiles and using the Iranian supplied
Kamikaze drones that we've heard so much
about and what's been the impact then on
the city
well the cities themselves it's
attacking centers of Civilian population
um it's attacking um living
accommodation it's attacking um areas of
par infrastructure and water
infrastructure and it's causing huge
Devastation these are cities and times
that we could be walking through any
like any time there is in Europe where
people are preparing for Christmas and
then the missiles come in and we see the
level of Destruction that we've got on
the screen here it's horrific it's
attacking the people this in itself is a
war crime and Philip there has been
talks of preparation for counter-attacks
then and this is not just from one side
this is by both sides so what impact and
is this going to cause then on the
ground currently yes it's it's
interesting you know the Ukrainian
minister of defense last night turned
around and talked about the Russians
preparing for
um uh counter-attacks and within that
there's elements of one guards tank Army
preparing inside Belarus and training
and bringing a lot of the reservists
that we've heard so much about over the
past few weeks um into train with them
on about a three-month training package
that that's what you want to do just
before you carry out a counter-offensive
and the ukrainians would want to get
that out there because it is telling the
West keep supplying us weapons keep
supplying us ammunition that we need
um whilst the ukrainians if we go into
the um the East itself the the
ukrainians are actually defending and
stopping the Russian attacks in around
the bakmut region that we've heard so
much about again over coming weeks and
the Russians have put a defensive line
up near salvatovi
um in case the uh the ukrainians decide
to attack in through there the
ukrainians have gone silent when they go
silent they tend to be preparing for
some form of action we saw that just
before they took the big yellow area
near heart cave and when they took
Harrison in the South and they're fixing
the Russians in that back mode area so
they're they're keeping them there which
would give them options to come in
through the North or come in through the
South and donesque if they were going to
do a counter-offensive they want the
ground to be hard for that so as it's
freezing hard at the moment we're
getting closer to that potentially
happening absolutely Philip thank you